hi there
steven crowder happy fourth burden and
pendants day if you prefer I prefer
fourth because it's easier to say I'm
also wildly uncomfortable as you are now
I'm sure the viewer we're here with
David Barton wall builder while builder
sorry is the organization and he's sort
of like the of the MacGyver of
historical artifacts you give him the
bentback paper clip and an empty straw
and he will give you the Declaration of
Independence he just finds them out of
nowhere today we'll be talking about
specifically the First Amendment freedom
of speech of if I can just sort of wedge
myself out you're not the same as those
those fourth grade kids upsetting there
in 1880 90s a little bigger especially
because they were very malnourished and
I assumed quite quite often beaten so
first off let's for people who aren't
necessarily entirely aware in a nutshell
what is the First Amendment what does it
guarantee in the United States the First
Amendment is part of the Bill of Rights
it recognizes rights that exist and says
the people have a right to do these
things and that government is not to
touch those things so the First
Amendment contains five rights that says
government cannot regulate these rights
they don't belong to the government and
you have the right free exercise of
religion you have the right of speech
you have the right of press you have the
right of petition and the right of
assembly right so those are the five
rights now unfortunately only one in a
thousand Americans can name the five
rights in the First Amendment so we
don't even know what they are generally
right but those are five things that the
government is not to interfere with and
limit and regulate right is this
uniquely American does this exist
anywhere else in the world particularly
freedom of speech as an absolute it did
but it was all for example Great Britain
we had all of these rights in Great
Britain and part of the reason the
founders explained that we separated
from Great Britain was King George the
third kept violating these rights
some of these were set out back in the
Magna Carta so these have always been
recognized as natural rights god-given
rights and a little rights different
terms they've been written about by John
Locke and the 1690s or Montesquieu in
the 1750s other nations other
philosophers grocers and poof and Dorf
they're Dutch philosophers
a lot of people wrote about them not
many nations hadal but in the British
system they did exist but they were
regularly violated because in the
British system you didn't have three
branches that were separated you had
three branches but the Kings over
everything said the King went bad it all
that combined with a taxation without
representation ended up with entire
buckets of Twinings in Earl Grey being
dumped into the harbor
so what's it for people maybe they just
think it starts with the First Amendment
but you have some context here that sort
of led to that right this is what you're
saying this is the zinger yeah this is
this case is the case and trial of Peter
zinger now let me set the background
even before that I'm gonna go back here
to an act of Parliament and this goes
back in the 1600s
16:46 this is so this is passed in June
or December 16 46 and it's a law of
Parliament on whoever can preach the
gospel of the scripture so they're
saying here's what you can account say
we will tell you who can say religious
wow that's so that's a law of Parliament
on who can and cannot have religious
speech okay who can and cannot say
things about the gospel yeah so this is
the British mindset is you have free
speech but will tell you what you can
say and who can say it and etc and so
what kind of like the British mindset
today where they jail someone for doing
a cover of kungfu fighting because it's
hate speech but yeah that seems more
regal well yeah that's more regal back
then because you had parliament doing so
what they get into is what that kind of
mindset in America there's a lot of
government interference with American
Americans are much more aware of their
rights they did a lot of reading of
those guys we talked about the locks and
Montesquieu's and groceries from Puu
front door they knew they knew rice and
they knew in a liberal rights and they
knew that government existed to protect
rights and the Great Britain is not
doing that one of those rights was
freedom of the press so freedom the
press what happened was you had a
governor in New York governor Cosby who
the people thought did some really
crummy things a heavy one to Cosby
always a Cosby all right he did he did
some inappropriate things we should say
so we'll say inappropriate is the word
there yeah so did their appropriate
things and a newspaper publisher Peter
zinger criticized
that in writing he didn't impress the
British courts took him and jailed him
for years said the law says you can't
criticize the king or the government and
that's British law you can't do that he
did it so when it went to trial and this
took place where this took place in New
York City in 1735 okay so he goes to
trial in seventeen well actually they
jailed him in 1734 and so in 1735 a year
in jail for criticizing the government
he is at trial and he has two really
good attorneys the judge dissin borrowed
the attorney said you think you got in
here good so it singer you got a singer
now so he had a singer men yes
representing probably yeah yeah that's
team right so they get disbarred and
they choose this young attorney who
doesn't have any experience and you can
defend him and so his defense to the
jury is very strong he says look he may
criticize the government but what he
said was true yeah and the jury went
back and said truth is an absolute
defense he may have criticized the
government but if what you say is true
then that's fine you're allowed to
criticize you have the right of free
speech you can criticize the government
what you say is true and so that jury
decision that overturned what the judges
were doing and the one thing that the
British did get right at that point in
time was the jury has the final word and
so in cases like that and William Penn
who found in Pennsylvania that when the
jury said that's it that was the end of
and the British at least did respect
that so that became the foundation of
freedom of press that's interesting that
in that building where the trial
occurred is the same building in which
we framed the Bill of Rights to give
freedom of the press right so is there
sitting there framing that it's just you
know it's like right there we had the
trial right so this is all cognizant to
Americans because this is all part of
protecting those natural right again no
kind of like we were talking about
before you know this was when they were
shared fundamental values truth is an
absolute defense that's right but you
were also telling me more I think we
have some over there kind of fake news
if it wasn't true it wasn't always
defensible right this is this is kind of
fun stuff over here so let me pull some
stuff out I'll just let you take the
first shot at this
this is an old law book this is one of
the state law books this happens to be
out of Virginia and here's the whole
section what's the section titled false
Newt false news
so there's false news here's what you do
in false news you got the right to news
you have the right to freedom the press
and speech you don't have the right to
lie and so what happens is you can lie
but you need to be held accountable for
it so this is where we would provide
provisions and here's another one of the
law books with this this kind of fake
news stuff and so what would happen here
if I can get to it you know again this
is an act against the vultures of false
news well so if you're saying something
that's a lie and that hurts somebody's
reputation he's got a right to defend
his reputation right so you got it you
got to make a way to punish people who
intentionally say something false or
that do things that hurt your reputation
today we've made it very very very hard
to sue for defamation and in course
today you have to show that there was
great economic harm so if somebody
slanders me or reliables me it's only
slander libel if it's hurting me
economically they don't count reputation
to something right these guys thought
your reputation is everything so there
were a lot of laws that said you can't
you you have freedom press and speech
but you also have to be accountable this
is one thing I love about what the
Founding Fathers did with every right in
the Bill of Rights they said for every
right there's a corresponding
responsibility and duty so I've got the
right to free speech but I have the duty
to tell the truth when I speak I have
the right to keep and bear arms but I
have the duty not to shed innocent blood
you know so everything had had a
responsibility and so that no no this
was false news is that just applied to
the press or that also apply to personal
freedom of both here's here's a press
one this is great it says on the front
letters from General George Washington
and so this is dated 1796 but I want to
show you the first letter you show it to
them so they can see he begs looks like
it's coming up it is it's old so George
Washington and these are letters from
George Washington but I'm gonna open it
up here and the first thing you'll be
using tweezers or something I mean like
if I have a first issue printing of the
thing a comic book and if I if I bend
the crease it's worth nothing
well that it's your right and that's why
we hold these to about 60 to 90 degrees
open we don't let them go open all the
way and we don't use gloves because
gloves you don't have the sensitivity
and so if I use a glove I'm invariably
going to tear that paper
okay now gloves are good for artifacts
and I'll keep my fingers off the press
off the printed part but on the edges
that's how we can tell that that's how
we can tell how soft the paper is so
what we have there's letters from George
Washington this is June the 12th of 1776
so we have Washington in the middle of
the revolution this is a letter that was
printed by from Washington apparently in
a New York newspaper and in this letter
Washington takes this tone of I don't
know what to do here what I'm doing in
this revolution is the wrong thing we
shouldn't be doing this we don't have a
moral right to do this I don't think
this is going to turn out right the
whole thing is just a real downer except
he never said anything that was the
press making that up I was gonna say
doesn't sound like my George oh that's
right it was not George this was done by
a newspaper editor in New York to build
sentiment against the Revolution you get
the Patriots these guys are all radicals
are all crazy Washington doesn't even
think they're right and everybody loved
Washington so right you know even so
this this was the press doing false news
and what were the consequences for that
well apps the guy got exposed first
thing was when they exposed it and
America still had enough of moral fiber
back then they didn't like being lied to
sure and so at that point in time that's
it he's kind of he's no longer press guy
anymore because I'm was gonna buy stuff
right so that was exposure but on the
other hand you have a founding father
like Benjamin Rush is a signer of the
Declaration and as a signer of the
Declaration he was John Adams said he's
one of the three most notable signers of
three most notable founders John Adams
said you had Washington and Franklin and
Benjamin Rush and he's not often talked
about he's not often talked to you I
think he wrote fly-by-night I seen it
not at all no not this but he was
amazing
I mean he he's the father of public
school son of the Constitution started
five universities he's the most famous
physician in American history he has
medical cures 200 years ago we still use
today well he had a critic back then
there's a guy named William Kovac
that just absolutely would not let up on
him in the papers he's a quack he's a
killer he's killing his patients he's
sure this too for them sorry I know yeah
I'm sorry you could all feel telling me
that's right I'm selfish that way you
know this is just so that this is an
action this is a court report and what
happened this guy beat onrush for years
and years and years and rush ignored him
as much as he could and finally he said
you know my reputation I got to do
something so he took the guy to court
and in court he won a huge settlement
against the guy so back then was that
like 4 nickels it was back then his
$5,000 okay that wouldn't even get you
an attorney hired today but back then
that was a huge settlement yeah back
then and so $5,000 and he gave it all to
charity because what he wanted was his
reputation back he didn't want the press
haven't and this guy particularly who
was writing in the press so an
individual action against a person and
rush wanted in court and that stopped
the guy had no more criticism of him
after that rush got his reputation back
and even today Russ are considered and
viewed very highly yeah that was a big
thing a lot of people understand that
nowadays when people say them's fightin
words it usually wasn't from being
physically assault that's right back
then your reputation was worth something
protecting or the reputation of your
wife right this was something that
people they would they would go to blows
over and now we're talking it would go
to duels over yeah I know Julian was
really common when you think about that
you know a couple of punches in a bar
fight seems like nothing of somebody
ruins my reputation but back then they
were pretty severe and it seems like
we've lost a little bit of that and
we've also lost some accountability I've
often talked of this in hockey it's the
only sport where there's accountability
because the ref will let you go you
earned this one Mark Messier exactly no
that was in contests you were telling me
rush to Jefferson Thomas Jefferson and
what happened in the election of 1800
was Thomas Jefferson the the libel and
slander against him has reached a level
that has never been seen in any other
political campaign we talk about
negative campaigning day we're a bunch
of wimps I mean you read what was said
about Jefferson Van Kent he was a
murderer he killed a wife and eight kids
and he he's abolishing the Navy and he's
he's you know he's finding every Bible
and he's collecting them and burning
them I mean the stuff that was out about
sounds like Bernie 2020 but yes there
you go
well they nothing changes over time two
years later only one actually didn't
happen so so he's got all this stuff and
we've got a whole bunch of these
articles about him this this negative
stuff and he's writing his friends and
saying that's not true and we all know
that's not true and the history's proven
it wasn't true and this is the period of
time in which he was accused with father
and chili children and Sally Hemings
regulator and - why do people still
believe that well in November of 1998
the report came out by Joseph Ellis's
and nature and science magazine said we
now have DNA evidence Jefferson did it
we know he did it actually Eugene
Foster's the guy who did the DNA test I
talked to Eugene we talked to him he
said no I told him that we did not even
use Jefferson's DNA and the testing and
so what happened Joseph Ellis was a huge
fan of Bill Clinton and Bill Clinton was
being impeached for the Monica Lewinsky
stuff at the time and he thought you
know if we can say Jefferson did that we
can say Jefferson was a great president
this had no effect on his presidency and
so Ellis had actually been part of a
full-page ad in new york times on how
great Jefferson was shouldn't be
impeached and this seemed to help it so
when when the piece came out or and by
the way we talked to Eugene Foster he
did a second testing DNA testing and the
same thing
there's no evidence that Jefferson
Thomas Jefferson did this so to this day
everybody knows there were 211 news
outlets that carried the announcement
that Jefferson did it six weeks later
they pulled the story back to F sorry we
were wrong with only 11 outlets carried
the retractions was it kind of one of
those first story front-page retraction
somewhere in the sports section that's
right in the advertisement section
somewhere next to Garfield in the comics
exactly and so people today still think
Jefferson did with Jefferson back then
he said I'm not gonna take these guys to
court he said I could easily disprove
them in court I can show he said but you
know what I trust the good judgement of
the people I trust that there's a God in
heaven before whom these Liars will
stand and they'll have to account to him
he went through three reasons he just
didn't think it was worth taking the
court it's interesting today
one of the reasons the critics of
Jefferson used to say he never denied
the affair with Sally him is therefore
his guilty of it ya know so he's a guy
that did not take advantage of his
ability to prove his innocence back then
and today we say well he must have done
it
so but rush did and and so we have a
different opinion right the people who
might be a little nervous hearing this
thing Oh course okay you shouldn't lie
commit libel or slander but there is
some concern that someone in power can
more easily say well that's that's not
true that's libel or slander and they
have the ability to tip the scales of
justice and that's what people would say
about Donald Trump for example then well
this is true he just doesn't like it and
so that's where there are more
protections of the press yeah there was
there was a lot of cost of action back
then and a jury of your peers as what
decided the government didn't decide the
jury decided and we don't do this
anymore today but at the time of the
founding fathers if a judge overturned a
jury decision that was an impeachable
offense for a judge you just did not do
that you did not know you didn't
overturn the will to people right today
judges are all the time sitting inside
jury breaks oh that amount was too much
she got to sit aside so their defense
back then was the government this is our
protection because our peers will look
at it and say nah the paper was right
you were wrong and is there up has there
been precedent set to be really clear in
delineating between outright lies
fabrications and just having an opinion
that might be and so well not anymore
today because it is so hard to sue for
your reputation
again you have to prove economic hurt
and the average American can't prove
these been economically hurt below the
swell of what's happening of Nick
Sandman I hope Nick Sandman does really
well that you know the kid on the mall
that there was a costume by the Native
American you know they come into school
and so he sued so many of these media
outlets and if he is able to veil on
that then people start getting the
reputation back but but I want to make
sure people understand that the First
Amendment still would protect for
example op-eds that are unpopular or
opinion pieces that's right opinion
piece but when you come out and make it
fact right and you said George
Washington wrote this no that was a
fabrication all the way around right and
you didn't do do you see we we hold
doctors liable for malfeasance if they
don't do due diligence right and for a
reporter not to do did now if you want
to say this is my opinion here's an
opinion piece you got it you
I say Donald Trump is an idiot George
Bush was wrong about Iraq
he's a crappy President Barack Obama
sucks people can say that so outside of
lying outside of libel and slander are
there any limitations on individual
speech as it relates to the First
Amendment the limitations are
accountability of telling the truth or
at least not hurting someone's
reputation for life well it's not only
that I think it's even more pure than
that it really is distilled the truth
because people often say well you can't
yell fire in a crowded theater that's
right you can if there's a fire you
can't lie because that could cause
physical harm to somebody people will
get trampled that that is the moral
sense that was there was truth was the
bottom line
you're after truth and we may have
differences of opinion that's why you
see rarely see slander or libel cases in
the in the abolition time because there
was two opinions all right the worth of
blacks those are opinions but to
absolutely come out and say that you
said this when you didn't or that I
accuse you or something you had no part
in that's were across the line it's
interesting that like you said that
there was a time where these were sort
of shared moral values where we said
okay if we're going to have freedom of
speech which is a pretty radical idea
like you said it existed obviously in
the old land but it wasn't necessarily
enforced equally but we said we are
going to have true freedom of speech
there was a shared value that truth is
really important whereas when we've
moved away from that now people don't
even understand the First Amendment
where they say you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater well it's not about
yelling fire it's about the truth
I say well hold on a second you
shouldn't say this on campus well it's
not about it being offensive is someone
saying something that is untrue and it's
really become a territory that it's it
with my generation kids have no grasp of
it and they say it's reductive but I do
think the First Amendment really can be
incredibly reductive it comes down to
are you telling the truth it's Rob are
you knowingly lying that's right I
should say because people can be wrong
and intent was a large part of it right
you know that I mean of course the the
the jewel-case with the bombing in
Atlanta 96 the newspapers held liable
and others that reported it were also
liable but intent was a big deal you had
to have an intent to lie not tell the
truth to hurt someone with with
falsehoods and that intent was really
big if it was innocent that was one
thing and it really can be boiled down
to it then first
applies to all it is absolute provider
that you are not knowingly lying
that's offense it's covered unpopularity
it's covered something that really
bothers somebody or might be even
knowingly hurtful of someone's feelings
but not dishonest it's covered
dishonesty is the one and that was why
with every right there's a corresponding
responsibility you got a right to free
speech free press but you have a
responsibility to tell the truth right
and what let me ask you this this is
kind of a little bit more macro we do
have to get going we have some other
installments of course I click the
button watch them on YouTube for example
Bernie Sanders to go back to Bernie
Sanders has talked about how the Boston
bomber shouldn't lose his right to vote
or even let's scale it back because I
was a headline that convicted violent
felons maybe shouldn't lose their right
to vote what was the idea from the
founding fathers for example if you
violated those responsibilities with
those rights for example let's say of
course you had the right to carry a
firearm but if you shot somebody and
killed somebody
what to what degree would you lose
access to those right you know it's an
interesting thing because we look at at
voting as a right they did not they
didn't see voting right they saw this
responsibility it was a duty it was
something you owed it was you choosing
your government under which you live and
if you've committed a heinous crime you
shouldn't be choosing the leaders
because your whole moral sense of skewed
if you think it's okay to take
somebody's life you're not the one we
won't choose in our leaders right and so
there was an exclusion that happened
there you have proven yourself unworthy
of knowing the moral sense of what your
leader should be and so for them there
was a penalty and even as I grew up in
school because I obviously have white
hair you don't it was it was a big deal
to lose your right to vote and that was
that was a deterrent to crime actually
voting was so important to us that when
we were reminded that if you did this
you lose your right to vote I'm not
gonna do that that was actually a
deterrent it would not be today right
because we're so sloppy with that right
and we don't share where you can lose
your right obviously to carry a firearm
that's right and that that was big stuff
yeah and so we understood how important
those rights were now we're kind of an
entitlement mentality this is what the
government owes me and it's not those
were rights that we exercised and so
at that point that the right to choose
self-government to choose leaders who
would not be corrupt who would not
exercise power wrongly who would keep
government limited except that was a
really big deal but we don't teach that
civic responsibility the same way so
today we just throw anybody that has two
legs or one leg or no leg or anybody can
vote you know and you don't you have to
live here you don't have to be part of
the cut but not anybody can have the
right to speak freely or on a firearm
which you know there are number one and
two when you look at the amendments all
right mr. Barton thank you very much
watch more we have installments on the
Civil War Revolutionary War Second
Amendment happy fourth it's itchy